.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Mein Name ist Patrik Gerber.
Ich bin 23 Jahre alt, wohne in
Moosseedorf und bin Medizinstudent.
Und Sie haben
einen Freund im Todestrakt.
Genau, ja.
Dieser Brieffreund wartet in den USA,
im Bundesstaat Florida,
auf seine Hinrichtung.
Mein Name ist William Kopsho.
Ich bin seit 21 Jahren im Gefängnis.
Ich wurde zum Tode verurteilt,
weil ich jemandem
das Leben genommen habe.
Ein Verein namens lifespark
vermittelt seit fast 30 Jahren
Brieffreundschaften mit Menschen,
die in der Todeszelle sitzen.
Und je mehr ich von ihm erfuhr,
dachte ich mir:
"Ich würde es keine zwei Tage
dort im Gefängnis aushalten."
Ich hatte erwartet,
dort Monster vorzufinden.
Doch was ich dort vorfand,
waren Menschen.
Sollte er je das Datum
für die Umsetzung seiner Todesstrafe
erhalten,
dann müsste wohl eher
er mich trösten als ich ihn.
In vielen Fällen
entstehen tiefe Freundschaften -
im Wissen darum, dass das Gegenüber
irgendwann hingerichtet wird.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Medizinstudent Patrik Gerber
lernt für eine Prüfung.
Irgendwie immer mit dabei:
sein Brieffreund William Kopsho -
seit einigen Jahren
einer seiner engsten Vertrauten,
trotz rund 40 Jahren
Altersunterschied.
Wenn ich Prüfungen habe,
versucht er immer,
mich fürs Lernen zu motivieren,
und sorgt dafür,
dass ich mich wegen der Prüfungen
nicht zu sehr stresse.
Prüfungsstress im Studium
beschäftigt den einen,
die bevorstehende Exekution
den anderen.
Bei solchen Brieffreundschaften
prallen Welten aufeinander.
Ich sagte ihm mal, dass ich mich
fast nicht trauen würde,
ihm davon zu erzählen
angesichts der Situation,
in der er sich befindet.
Doch er meinte, ich solle ihm
unbedingt davon erzählen,
denn es seien Themen,
die in meinem Leben relevant sind.
Er möchte,
dass ich ihm davon erzähle.
Er möchte Teil meines Lebens sein
und darin
einen Platz als Freund haben.
Ja, das ist toll.
Wenn er Urlaub macht
oder mit Freunden essen geht,
schickt er mir Fotos.
Das gibt mir das Gefühl,
dabei zu sein.
Und das ist wunderbar.
Durch ihn fühle ich mich
zwischendurch wie ein freier Mann -
zumindest in meinem Geist.
Patrik Gerber
wollte sich sozial engagieren
und las zufällig einen Artikel
über Brieffreundschaften
mit Menschen in der Todeszelle.
Also meldete er sich beim Verein
und bekam einen Gefangenen zugeteilt.
Dem schrieb er zuerst Briefe,
heute E-Mails.
Würden Sie uns erzählen,
was Sie getan haben?
Lieber nicht.
Wer meinen Namen googelt,
findet viele Informationen.
Aber das ist nicht
die ganze Wahrheit.
Patrik kennt die ganze Wahrheit.
Er schreibt,
dass sie sich gestritten hätten.
Sie hätte ihn betrogen,
und er sei tief verletzt gewesen.
Die Ehe sei nicht
nach seinen Vorstellungen verlaufen.
Alles sei
sehr überraschend gekommen.
Er hätte mit ihr reden wollen.
Er habe zwar eine Waffe
zum Gespräch mitgenommen,
aber ganz klar nicht
mit der Absicht, sie zu töten,
sondern als Druckmittel,
damit sie mit ihm spricht.
Die Situation sei dann eskaliert
und sie sei davongerannt.
Er habe die Waffe geladen,
auf sie geschossen
und sie tödlich getroffen.
Kurz danach habe er
die Polizei angerufen und gesagt,
dass er seine Frau getötet habe
und sie kommen sollten,
um ihn zu verhaften.
Keine fünf Minuten später sei der
erste Streifenwagen eingetroffen,
und seither ist er in Haft.
Das war im Oktober 2000.
Ich will, dass alle wissen,
dass ich meine Tat sehr bereue.
Und ich schäme mich auch für das,
was ich getan habe.
Ich habe vielen Menschen
sehr wehgetan -
der Familie des Opfers
und meiner eigenen Familie.
Es tut mir unendlich leid.
Wenn ich noch mal zurückkönnte,
würde ich alles anders machen.
Kathrin Studers Korrespondenz
mit ihrem Brieffreund Luther
füllt bereits mehrere Ordner.
Sie sammelt alles,
was er ihr schickt:
Briefe, E-Mails und Karten.
In diesem Kärtchen z.B.
bedankt er sich dafür,
dass ich ihm
eine solche Freundschaft ermögliche.
Er würde sich
auf die tiefe Freundschaft freuen,
die wir mit der Zeit
gemeinsam aufbauen könnten.
Und das ist nun passiert.
- Ja, das ist nun passiert.
Daraus hat sich
eine tiefe Freundschaft entwickelt,
die mir viel bedeutet.
Ihr Brieffreund schreibt, wie es ist,
rund um die Uhr
in einer Zelle zu sitzen
und von seinen Höhepunkten:
zweimal Hofgang pro Woche.
Und was schreiben Sie ihm?
Wenn ich mit mir selber hadere,
frustriert oder unzufrieden bin -
allein beim Gedanken an ihn,
denke ich,
welch blöde Kuh ich doch bin
und wie gut es mir geht
im Vergleich zu ihm.
Sie betreut ihren Mann Daniel,
der an einer Augenkrankheit leidet.
Keine einfache Aufgabe.
Aber es ist bekanntlich
alles relativ.
Ich kann einfach nach draussen gehen
und es geniessen.
Das wird mir dann schon bewusst.
Seit ich ihn kenne,
geniesse ich mein Leben mehr.
Durch ihn
wurde mir vor Augen geführt,
was ich alles habe,
was er nicht hat,
und wie gut es mir eigentlich geht.
Patrik Gerber will Arzt werden
und die Welt bereisen.
Ihm sei bewusst geworden,
was für ein Privileg es sei,
Pläne haben zu dürfen
und frei zu sein.
Ein amerikanischer Pfarrer,
der Todestraktinsassen betreut,
antwortete auf die Frage,
wie es denn im Todestrakt sei:
"Stellen Sie sich vor, Sie hätten
ein Haus mit einem Badezimmer."
"Gehen Sie in dieses Badezimmer,
klappen Sie den WC-Deckel zu,
setzen Sie sich darauf
und stellen Sie die Klimaanlage ab -
und nun stellen Sie sich vor,
dass das für die nächsten
drei Jahrzehnte Ihr Zuhause ist."
"Und wenn Sie nun noch
alle sozialen Beziehungen wegdenken,
wissen Sie,
wie es ungefähr im Todestrakt ist."
Vergleicht man diese Vorstellung mit
den Freiheiten, die man sonst hat,
wird einem bewusst,
wie extrem die Situation ist.
Meine Freiheit ist hier drin,
in meinem Herzen.
Da fühle ich meine Freiheit.
Wenn ich auf dem Hof bin und
Felder sehe, dann belastet es mich.
Ich war schon als Kind
gerne draussen.
Ich liebte es,
lange Waldspaziergänge zu machen.
Dort habe ich immer
eine Verbindung zu Gott gespürt.
Ich vermisse das sehr.
Angela Heeb schreibt schon seit
Jahrzehnten Menschen im Todestrakt,
oft mehreren parallel.
Für sie als Pensionärin
und Junggesellin ein ideales Hobby,
das ihr helfe, zu verhindern,
dass ihr Englisch, das sie sonst
nur noch wenig brauche, einroste.
War es von Anfang an
Teil Ihrer Motivation,
dass Sie Ihr Englisch
aufbessern möchten?
Ja.
Und vielleicht auch,
um ein wenig sozial tätig zu sein.
Aber vorwiegend
wegen meiner Englischkenntnisse.
Zudem schreibe ich auch gerne.
Auch in jungen Jahren,
als wir noch kein Telefon hatten,
schrieb ich schon viel.
Wenn ich verreiste, schrieb ich
bis zu zwanzig, dreissig Postkarten.
Das war mein Hobby.
In den Ferien sass ich abends auf
dem Balkon und schrieb Postkarten.
Ich erhielt auch gerne welche.
Das sind Bilder, die ich
den Insassen schicken möchte.
Was für Bilder?
Z.B. dieses Bild,
auf dem eine Person eine Kuh
statt ein Pferd reitet.
Oder hier ein Bild
mit einem Schweizer Brauch:
dem Alpsegen.
Oder hier ein Bild
von einem Schweizer Grab.
Ich wäge jeweils das Couvert
und fülle es noch mit Sachen,
bis es 20 g wiegt.
Haben Sie diesen Menschen auch schon
Fotos von sich selbst geschickt?
Ich mache selten Fotos von mir.
Aber ja, ich habe auch schon
Fotos von mir geschickt.
Insbesondere dann,
wenn ich in den Ferien war
und andere Fotos von mir schossen.
Aber ich selbst
mache kaum welche von mir.
Ich durfte einmal an einem Beauty-
Tag der "GlücksPost" teilnehmen.
Und ich habe dann das Bild
von diesem Beauty-Tag geschickt.
* Angela Heeb schmunzelt. *
Und wie waren die Rückmeldungen?
- Allesamt positiv.
Viele sagten, man würde mich
auf den Bildern gar nicht erkennen.
Ja ...
Sie schreiben ja schon
eine Weile mit ihm.
Haben Sie
im Verlaufe der Zeit gemerkt,
dass es auch bei Ihnen
etwas verändert hat?
Laut meinem Mann, ja.
Er findet, dass ich ruhiger
und geerdeter geworden bin.
Als mein Mann vor zwei Jahren wegen
seiner Krankheit zum IV-Fall wurde,
haderte auch ich mit der Situation.
Ich hatte mir das Leben
vielleicht anders vorgestellt.
Als dann mein Mann
jeden Tag mit mir zu Hause war,
begann gleichzeitig
auch diese Brieffreundschaft.
Mein Mann sagt, ich hätte mich
dadurch stark verändert.
Sie ermöglicht es mir,
mich wieder etwas zurückzuziehen.
Er fragt schon nach, worüber er
schreibt und wie es ihm geht.
Oder manchmal möchte er,
dass ich ihn etwas frage -
wie er dieses oder jenes
machen würde.
Aber es ist meine Brieffreundschaft.
So kann ich mich wieder zurückziehen
und für mich sein.
Und es tut mir sehr gut,
wieder etwas für mich zu haben,
mit dem ich mich abgrenzen kann.
Kathrin Studers Brieffreund erfuhr
im Gefängnis von der Möglichkeit,
mit jemandem aus der Schweiz
in Kontakt zu kommen
und liess sich
auf eine Warteliste setzen.
Oft dauert es Monate oder Jahre,
bis sich jemand findet.
Wer also Kapazität hat,
darf mehreren schreiben.
Wir haben
einen sehr intensiven Briefwechsel.
Ich schreibe ihm fast täglich.
Eine zweite Brieffreundschaft
liegt da kaum drin.
Wenn ich noch mit einer zweiten
Person so intensiv schreiben würde,
dann hätte ich keine Zeit mehr
für andere Dinge.
Ich fände es dieser Person gegenüber
nicht gerecht,
ihr sozusagen Hoffnungen zu machen,
denn diese Personen sind enorm
dankbar oder darauf angewiesen,
dass sie jemanden
zum Schreiben haben.
Und das wäre nicht fair.
Daher im Moment eher nicht.
Könnte es auch daran liegen,
dass Ihr Brieffreundschaftsherz
schon vergeben ist?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Aus einer Zweierbeziehung
ist in den vergangenen Jahren
zunehmend
eine Dreierbeziehung geworden.
Guten Appetit!
- Guten Appetit!
Der Brieffreund ist omnipräsent
im Leben der Studers.
Wie finden Sie es,
dass Ihre Frau täglich
Kontakt mit Ihrem Brieffreund hat?
Als das Ganze seinen Anfang nahm,
sprachen wir darüber
und ich fand das in Ordnung.
Für sie ist es eine Abwechslung.
Für sie ist es gut.
Und für Sie?
Ich akzeptiere es.
So wie es ist, ist es in Ordnung.
Das Delikt sei kein Thema
zwischen ihr und ihrem Brieffreund,
sagt Kathrin Studer.
* Sanfte Musik *
Sie wisse nur,
dass er verurteilt wurde -
wegen Vergewaltigung und Mord.
Dass sie so jemanden
in ihr Leben gelassen hat,
verstehen nicht alle.
* Sanfte Musik *
Meine Tochter war demgegenüber mehr
als ein Jahr lang sehr skeptisch.
Sie konnte es irgendwie
nicht verstehen.
Mein Mann war deswegen
nie eifersüchtig,
aber ich glaube, dass meine Tochter
in gewisser Weise befürchtete,
dass ich nun sozusagen
zwei Männer hätte.
So wirkte es auf mich.
Meine Schwester war dagegen,
weil sie Angst hatte - im Sinne von:
"Das ist ein Mörder."
"Stell dir vor,
wenn er irgendwann mal rauskommen
und zu dir kommen sollte
und dir auch was antut."
Ich sehe es als eine Art Ventil.
Wenn sie etwas hat,
das sie beschäftigt -
ob es nun um uns direkt geht
oder nicht -,
dann hat sie jemanden,
dem sie es erzählen kann.
Andere Frauen telefonieren
stundenlang mit anderen Frauen.
Und dann denke ich mir ...
Er betrachtet es als Mann
und gibt ihr eine Antwort
auf dieses Problem.
Ich denke, er betrachtet es
aus einer dritten Perspektive
und nicht einfach frontal.
Und ich denke, das ist gut so.
Und es ist nicht jemand,
der es dann weitererzählt,
sondern es bleibt
doch irgendwie in der Familie.
* Der Reporter lacht. *
Ja.
Würden Sie ihn denn
schon fast zur Familie zählen?
Ja.
Auch für Patrik Gerber trat das
Delikt schnell in den Hintergrund:
Aus einem fremden Mörder
wurde ein enger Freund.
Ich wollte ihn nicht
meinen Enkel nennen
und er mich nicht Vater oder so.
Also habe ich entschieden,
ihn Bruder zu nennen.
Denn ich konnte mit meinen Eltern
nie so offen reden,
wie ich es mit meinem Bruder konnte.
Also ist er
eine Art jüngerer Bruder für mich.
Und wir verstehen uns grossartig.
Wir sind sehr offen.
Keiner hat vor dem anderen
je etwas versteckt.
Am Anfang kam es
zu einer beiderseitigen Irritation,
als Patrik Gerber seinem
tiefreligiösen Brieffreund sagte,
er sei schwul.
Seine Reaktion darauf
war etwas zweischneidig.
Einerseits bedankte er sich
für meine Offenheit
und sagte, er würde Menschen
grundsätzlich so nehmen,
wie sie seien,
ohne sie zu verurteilen.
Andererseits äusserte er dann
aber doch seine Bedenken
betreffend meiner Homosexualität.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Patrik, du kannst dich gegen
die Homosexualität entscheiden."
Das glaubte ich wirklich.
Er antwortete: "Mein Coming-out
war ein langer Prozess,
den ich nicht freiwillig
auf mich genommen hätte."
Da wurde mir klar,
wie falsch ich lag.
Ich denke schon, dass er hoffte,
dass ich mich diesbezüglich
umentscheiden würde.
Ich schrieb ihm dann
einen langen Brief und erklärte ihm,
wie es mir ergangen war.
Für niemanden ist es: "Es ist wie es
ist, dann leben wir es halt so."
Ich glaube, dass fast alle
einen Prozess durchmachen.
Lilia Allemann ist geschieden,
die Kinder sind erwachsen
und aus dem Haus.
Darum hat
die gebürtige Mexikanerin Zeit,
um spanisch-sprachigen Gefangenen
zu schreiben.
Sie hatte schon diverse Brieffreunde.
Einer blieb ihr besonders
in Erinnerung: Arturo.
Das sind Fotos
von meinem letzten Besuch.
Er trieb viel Sport,
er war ein starker Mann.
Das ist Arturo
bei seiner Taufe im Gefängnis.
Er bekehrte sich zu Jesus.
Er hatte Dinge gemacht, die er
bis zum Schluss zutiefst bereute.
Was denn?
Menschen umgebracht -
unter Einfluss von Alkohol
und Drogen.
Er hatte sich nicht unter Kontrolle
und machte Dinge,
die er später,
als er wieder clean war,
bis ans Ende seines Lebens bereute.
Die Schmerzen, die er
anderen Menschen zufügt hatte -
er war sich dessen bewusst,
aber er konnte nichts mehr ändern,
das Leben dieser Menschen
liess sich nicht mehr zurückbringen.
Der Verein lifespark ist nicht
religiös, Lilia Allemann schon.
Ihre Motivation ist Nächstenliebe.
Und der Glaube prägt auch
ihre Sicht auf die vielen Mörder,
mit denen sie
in Kontakt gekommen ist.
Ja, bravo, bravo!
Wir haben einen angeborenen Graus
gegenüber dieser Art von Taten,
und das ist korrekt und gut so.
Aber es ist nicht meine ...
Ich wurde nicht hierher gesendet,
um die Menschen zu richten.
Ich nehme es zur Kenntnis,
und manchmal kostet es mich
viel Überwindung.
Ich fokussiere mich
auf die Menschen.
Auf die Menschen,
für die Jesus gestorben ist.
Ich versuche, sie zu sehen,
wie Jesus sie sieht,
sonst habe ich keine Chance.
Hier noch ein Foto.
Es gibt auch Frauen,
die Gefängnisinsassen heiraten.
Hätten Sie sich je vorstellen können,
sich in einen Gefangenen
zu verlieben?
Also ich jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Aber ja ...
Ich fand ihn einen schönen Mann,
aber ich hätte mich nicht
verlieben wollen.
Auch von seiner Seite aus -
er sagte auch, dass das nicht ginge,
dass wir keine Partnerschaft
haben könnten.
In diesem Fall war es gegenseitig.
Obwohl ...
Er war ein guter Typ.
Ich fand ihn einen guten Typen.
Aber wir wussten, dass es für uns
keine gemeinsame Zukunft gab.
Es gab einen Moment ...
Man ist im Gefühlschaos
und durcheinander.
Wir haben die Sache
gemeinsam thematisiert.
Mit Arturo?
- Ja.
Er mochte mich.
Wir haben die Sache zusammen
thematisiert und beschlossen,
dass wir uns auf das
fokussieren wollen, was wir haben.
Auf die Freundschaft?
- Ja, auf die Freundschaft,
und dass wir die Sache
rein lassen wollen.
Viele der Gefangenen
haben eine Freundschaft,
und es kommt sehr oft vor,
dass sie aus dieser Freundschaft
eine Mutter machen.
Ich sage darum allen:
"Ich darf deine Freundin,
deine Kollegin, deine Begleiterin
oder deine Schwester in Christus
sein, aber nur das -
ich bin keine Mutter,
keine Ehefrau."
Nichts anderes, nur das.
Wenn der Tag der Hinrichtung gekommen
ist, dürfen die Gefangen Menschen,
die ihnen wichtig sind,
einladen, dabei zu sein.
Auch ihre Brieffreundinnen,
wenn sie wollen.
Wissen Sie noch, welche Gefühle Sie
an diesem Tag hatten?
Keine Gefühle.
Schockzustand.
- Schockzustand?
Ja, man fühlt eigentlich nichts.
Die Gefühle sind vorher
und nachher vorhanden.
Also zunächst einmal, wenn der Brief
mit dem Hinrichtungsdatum eintrifft,
dann kommen Gefühle hoch.
Und dann kommt auch Trauer hoch.
Aber wenn es dann so weit ist,
dann existiert man einfach.
Und danach kommen vielleicht
wieder Gefühle hoch,
aber während der Zeit,
in der es passiert ...
Das ist schon fast
eine Art Schockzustand.
(Kathrin Studer) Ich weiss nicht,
wie es mir gehen wird,
wenn er mir dann mal sagt:
"Ich habe das Datum erhalten,
wann ich umgebracht werde."
Ich denke, dass mich das dann
sehr aus der Bahn werfen wird.
Ich werde in diesem Moment wohl
auf meine Familie angewiesen sein,
dass sie mich auffängt.
Hatte Arturo Angst vor dem Tod?
Am Anfang schon.
Aber nach seiner Bekehrung
fühlte er ...
Er durfte Jesus
in seinem Alltag begegnen,
und damit ging
die Angst vor dem Tod verloren.
Während seiner letzten Tage
hatte er vollkommenen Frieden.
Man sah, dass er total locker war.
Dieses Foto wurde ein paar Tage
vor seiner Hinrichtung gemacht.
Er war total ruhig.
Ich habe gesehen ...
Im letzten Moment war er natürlich
mit seinen Nerven fast am Ende.
Er zitterte und so.
Es kann sein, dass er
ganz zum Schluss Angst bekam.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Aber über die Tage davor sagte er,
dass es die besten Tage
seines Lebens seien.
Die besten Tage seines Lebens.
Die Tage vor seiner Hinrichtung?
In den USA
ist die Todesstrafe hoch umstritten.
Viele Bundesstaaten
haben sie inzwischen abgeschafft
oder vollziehen sie nicht mehr.
Wir standen vor der Glasscheibe,
und er lag bereits drinnen
auf der Liege.
Er war bereits zugedeckt.
Man sah eigentlich
nur noch seinen Kopf.
Der Rest seines Körpers
war mit einem Leintuch bedeckt.
Dann durfte er
noch seine letzten Worte sagen.
Ich habe sozusagen
nichts verstanden.
Und dann wurde ihm
das Gift injiziert.
Wir Frauen standen einfach da.
Nach einer gewissen Wartezeit
kam der Arzt rein
und bestätige seinen Tod.
Wir verfolgten das Ganze einfach
durch die Glasscheibe.
Er verabschiedete sich
von uns allen.
Und ...
Es war ein sehr intensiver Moment,
aber ...
Dann sagte er zum Wächter,
dass er bereit sei.
Und dann bekam er ...
... das Gift verabreicht.
Die Zeit ist stehen geblieben.
Es war, als hätte es
keine Zeit mehr gegeben.
Und ...
Die Minuten fühlten sich
wie eine Ewigkeit an.
Bis ...
Bis ihn der Verantwortliche
für tot erklärte.
Ich dachte:
"Jetzt ist er zu Jesus gegangen."
"Jetzt ist er frei, wirklich frei."
"Jetzt ist er wirklich frei."
Wir blieben
noch etwa 15-20 Min. dort
und dann gingen alle.
Ich ging dann auch zurück ins Hotel.
Und wie ging es Ihnen?
Seltsamerweise hatte ich dann das
Gefühl, dass er zu mir gekommen war.
Ich sah an der Decke Lichter
und dachte:
"Er ist gekommen,
um mich zu verabschieden."
Sein Geist.
- Ja, das dachte ich.
Mir ging es relativ gut.
Ich sah diese Lichter
und konnte danach auch gut schlafen.
Und am nächsten Tag
bin ich dann schon wieder
zurück in die Schweiz geflogen.
Denkt man im Todestrakt
ständig über seine Hinrichtung nach?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Man versucht, das auszublenden.
Wenn man immer denkt:
"Bekomme ich wohl heute mein Datum?"
"Verliere ich meine Berufung?"
Das ist nicht gut.
Ich denke, die meisten Menschen
im Todestrakt versuchen,
sich mit anderen Dingen
zu beschäftigen,
z.B. mit einer Brieffreundschaft.
Patrik Gerber mit seinem Partner,
der schnell verstanden hat,
wie wichtig
diese Brieffreundschaft ist -
für Patrik Gerber, aber v.a. auch
für dessen Freund im Todestrakt.
Grundsätzlich braucht es
eine gewisse Offenheit dafür.
Man sollte auch schon ein wenig
in seinem Leben angekommen sein -
also wissen, was man möchte
und eine klare Meinung haben.
Und es ist sehr wichtig,
dass man Sachen durchziehen kann.
Das ist auch ein Qualitätsmerkmal
des Vereins lifespark:
langjährige Brieffreundschaften.
Zum Teil entstehen daraus sehr
Der Verein rät allen davon ab,
die es nicht durchziehen wollen,
denn für die Betroffenen
ist es schon einschneidend,
wenn man den Kontakt
einfach wieder abbricht.
Daher empfehle ich es niemandem,
der sich zwar schnell
für etwas begeistert,
aber nur für kurze Zeit.
Da ist die Gefahr zu gross,
dass der Kontakt im Sand verläuft.
Bald nach diesen Aufnahmen erfuhr
Patrik Gerber von seinem Brieffreund,
dass seine jahrelangen Rekurse gegen
das Todesurteil Erfolg gehabt hätten.
Die Todesstrafe sei in
lebenslange Haft umgewandelt worden.
Sind Sie glücklich darüber?
Äh ... nein.
Man ist nicht glücklich
über lebenslange Haft.
Sind Sie erleichtert?
Nein,
ich bin auch nicht erleichtert.
Als ich es den anderen Insassen
erzählt habe, sagten alle:
"Gratulation zur lebenslangen Haft!"
Was?
Wie kann man jemandem
zur lebenslangen Haft gratulieren?
Wenn ich
eine Erleichterung verspüre,
dann nicht,
weil ich nicht hingerichtet werde,
sondern weil ich nun
ein bisschen mehr Freiheiten bekomme
innerhalb des Gefängnisses
und darum Aufgaben übernehmen kann.
Was auch immer das sein wird.
Dass ich weiterleben darf,
muss einen Sinn haben,
und diesen Sinn will ich finden.
Ich bin sicher:
Gott hat einen Plan für mich.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Vielleicht hat ja tatsächlich
jemand Pläne mit uns und für uns.
Mit denen in Freiheit -
und mit den anderen.
Vielleicht geben sie einander
ja ein wenig Sinn -
die Freien den Gefangenen
und umgekehrt.
Viele Freunde sagten zu mir,
dass sie dankbar sind,
dass ihnen dieses Vertrauen
entgegengebracht wird
und man sie als Menschen wahrnimmt.
Das ist sehr wichtig für sie.
Man muss sie daran erinnern,
dass sie Menschen sind -
damit sie sich als solche verhalten.
* Sanfte Klänge *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022